[Musique]
parler du royal wedding in the wreck
active y aune ce qui s'est passé à la
télé this week end est very very big
bang
c'est parti dans ce nouveau jeu cyril
féraud il a posé une question dont la
réponse sans plutôt évidente surtout
pour certains ce n'est que l'intrus est
bon la mauvaise c'est être anglais c'est
ce que ça veut dire que je peux le dire
ou pas renvoyer son meilleur reporter
dans le public du mariage princier de
mais vu ce qu'ils considèrent comme une
ambiance de ouf pas certain d'aller
réveillonner chez lui l'eau 31 ans
montrent clairement de votre côté
écoutez avis c'est une ambiance folle et
ici à seignosse olivier benkemoun
lorsqu'il a à l'antenne face on a pu
voir ce qu'ils pensent
résultat du festival de cannes ce pas
trop rigide demain il sort également
dans toute la france ils d'entreprise
que vous m'avez vu olivier
t'arrive ça arrive on a vu notre valeur
qui pensent avoir fait le plus dur en
évitant une banane mais car nassar
trappe
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
question pour samuel etienne a fait
deviner un bruit étrange aux candidats
un animal très difficile à apprivoiser
attention à la maison aussi écouter ceci
maintenant je vous avoue c'est un petit
peu intrigant je mate et les anges
d'nrj12 aussi à ba écoute audoubert
temps déjà sur tout alors attention
spoiler alert pour les fans geagea et le
sport ça fait 200 milliards on s'en
doutait un peu vu la référence qui fait
qui prend excusez moi en parlant de
patinage et encore du boulot pour
charger en passementerie
c'est ce qu'on va trouver les contenus
retrouver mon copain koreus bravo c'est
incroyable dans un téléfilm sur la fin
du monde
il ya ainsi durant qui jouent une scène
de panique rappelant à la fin du monde
mais il trouve le temps de faire une
petite blague
j'adore et puis j'ai regarder koh lanta
aussi pendant une épreuve jérémy avec
une petite glissade ir tombe vraiment
mal denis brogniart fait la tête de tous
les zones noires
extra
les chances qu'ils font tout aussi mal à
donner deux cultures seront à la hauteur
compétition au poil
je rappelle qu'à me faisais la reine des
neiges
merci ils ont failli mais depuis son
diderot j'ai regardé le mariage princier
a bien su qu'un mariage sans benji ça
reste un événement suivi par deux
milliards de téléspectateurs puis le 2
milliards de téléspectateurs avec un
gotha la noblesse des duchesses a pu
savoir comment faire du beau monde qui
s'étaient pressés pour assister à la
cérémonie regardée
on est tombé sur la copine kelly elle a
été le déplacement assistent à
l'événement tout comme afida turner à la
patine tête aussi à petit la salle des
machines le fils de chris marquès et
elle a obtenu 6 les données propres
on a vu il a tout mis pour la première
sera gardé le chapeau faux-plat regarde
et hop ça sert à l'organisation du
mariage était impeccable bien sûr en
tant notre plus belle organisation les
invités ne s'attendait pas ce que sont
si longues ami avec dévotion
on a vu david beckham chercher les
issues de secours
james corden
la tête de thann en cours d'histoire et
serena williams qui s'écroulait dès le
premier set et après c'est sous
magnifique cérémonie les jeunes mariés
ont fait un tour en landau pour saluer
les gens venus leweurs ils ont vraiment
saluer tout le monde comme ça qu'ils
étaient très dures si beaucoup axel
alors ces jeunes vont ils sont duc et
duchesse de ce set
pourquoi avoir choisi ce titre comment
ça se passe il faut évidemment qu'il a
soignée donc si je peux dire oui il faut
que la place soit libre qui surtout il
ya des titres comprend plus à longueur
d'émissions de l'assistance dire quelque
chose murmurer quelques cochons couvées
coûtera provisionnera attentivement
cette séquence alors revenons évidemment
à ce que tu t'es super franchement c'est
la chance aidant il ya eu de la salle
depuis son exemple c'est ouf il bémol
mais oui ça l'ancien studio et
correspond sur six ou sept courts et
souvent c'est vrai héros fondation gère
toutes les chaînes infos étaient
mobilisés pour suivre le match principe
des fn bien sûr vu le lapsus de la
journaliste à mon avis était déjà en
duplex de la lune de miel pu gratter
regardez on va vous montrer le traître
qui a été le plus partagé une photo de
megan adolescente posant devant le pac
et le filet de boeuf
j'ai dit qu'à 30 cérémonie des infos un
peu nul on s'en fout un peu mais faut
combler le vide à l'antenne forcément il
sait qu'il y aura des asperges y aura
des peaux mates les pantalons d'ivresse
harry et william sont attachés par une
sangle à l'athénée vie
pour la série soit patrick adams
exactement qui a dit qu'il allait lui
offrir un mixeur jusqu'à dans son sac
abri ya toujours une paire de gants de
rechange te ment voilà les blondes
qu'avant non il n'y a pas un truc comme
ça
versez le soleil elle prend beaucoup de
ces news c'était vraiment les meilleurs
on l'a senti des commentaires du tout
premier invité au mariage
james blunt se sont là katia on l'a dit
tout à l'heure
[Musique]
et le frais le monde entier a présenté
ses félicitations au couple royal y
avait pas de raison que l'on fasse pas
de même en fronton et à demander aux
passants dans la rue d'adresser un
message en anglais harry et mégane pas
sûr qu'ils comprennent the marriage is
perfect et loarie zoo prochaine fois et
vite mis au delà pour la vie de la miel
us bonasse je ne comprends pas qu'on me
tire et canaris ont dit à fameux bug
qu'au lieu au synode est beau et juste
pour finir sur les mariages comme à tous
les mariages vous le savez on profite
tous les mariés tourner le dos pour dire
des saloperies sur les mariés et les
invités
les commentateurs sont pas privés sur
france2 regarder à stéphane bern comme
sur tf1 d'ailleurs un regarde vous voyez
arriver
jenny et béatrice avec le duc d'york
leur père elles sont connues pour leur
régime mais qui ne marche pas toujours
juste à l'entrée les spéculations
un mariage où tout le monde dit des
saloperies sur tout le monde ça nous a
rappelé l'émission de tf1 quatre
mariages pour une lune de miel
on vous a préparé un mix des deux safer
donnerait sa
[Musique]
la mairie mais pas top en a les pattes
au port d'al arich
l interface du taux s'est désolé
[Musique]
malheureusement pour une entraide mariée
elle aurait pu faire beaucoup
vous savez le mariage c'est le plus beau
jour grève c'est le plus beau cadeau
qu'on peut donner à celui qu'on aime et
qu'est ce que c'est long mais madame
pour sentez-vous à prendre pour époux
monsieur mounir ici présent c'est à huy
émouvant au nom de la loi
j'ai l'immense plaisir de vous déclarer
unis par le mariage
[Applaudissements]
camille amat et la quotidienne et dans
un instant on viendra jouer je vais vous
donner des chiffres sur le mariage vous
allez voir si vous allez voir que
stéphane bern il sait veinarde ou wells
et miami c'est vénère après un gars qui
sait et on venait me dire si vous êtes
d'accord et cloud pas ouais je sais
d'accord avec eux avec avec stéphane
bern
voilà je vous dis il était mineur et une
polémique dans les marseillais on va
revenir là dessus alors ça ça a beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup fait parler chez qui
si ça vous a beaucoup peiné également
vous allez nous dire si vous êtes plus
du côté des marseillais ou de
l'association 30 millions d'amis
et puis ils mangent une raclette dans le
métro non instruits verrez ça dans un
instant et les cherry on a des infos
bien sûr de laëtitia david et laura qui
n'ont pas réussi à trouver un
arrangement
bernard montiel nous donnera toutes les
infos koh lanta on a encore deux
nouvelles infos et on parlera des
révélations sur l'état psychologique des
candidats du jeu sachez que pascal
appelé par exemple un membre de thé pmp
pascal de koh lanta il sait confie à lui
et on aura l'enquète de baba tf1 est il
en train de flinguer arthur on verra
tout ça dans un instant pour le moment
mon camion quotidienne de france 5 et
reçoivent des experts vous le savez
c'est le principe de l'émission
maintenant je peux pas croire que le
programmateur a pas fait exprès qui a
passé une petite bague
vu les noms c'est pas une valve exprès
je peux pas le croire n'hésitez pas à
poser les vôtres en direct aux 41 555
est avec nous aujourd'hui philippe la
rate bonjour à vos côtés le professeur
france achète bonjour
versailles et c'est dimanche à 12h16
précise que patrick sébastien est
officiellement devenu le gouffre et
patrick était d'ailleurs à la tête des
années bonheur samedi soir visiblement
une de ses invités venaient pour la
première fois elle un peu surpris que
pas toi je suis violent dessus pour lui
donner des ordres quoi c'est magique
c'est tout ce qu'on aime chez patrick
c'est qu'il fait pas de différence
adulte ou enfant rien à [ __ ] ils
parlent mal à tout le monde sur le
plateau aller au fond dans la boue
en tout cas il a cartonné en série ce
soir il arrivé deuxième des audiences un
de vente r3 je suis parti en week-end à
may cry on n'a pas le pénaliste
évidemment bien sûr alors beaucoup de
gens disent que dd il a un petit
chouchou dans sa liste qui aurait les
clés de l'équipe déjà pour le mondial je
vous rassure ça s'appelle entendu en
alors gardien de but antoine griezmann e
antoine griezmann que et antoine
griezmann défenseur antoine griezmann à
2 antoine griezmann
benjamin mendy et antoine ce que je
préfère c'est la voix tellement monotone
de didier deschamps pour annoncer la
liste
ousmane dembélé on a imaginé didion duo
heckmann tubes français
françois non
nabil ngolo ousmane jibril
tout va trés senneurs
[Musique]
ngolo je m'appelle n golo
je suis une fille
[Musique]
je me présente
je ne
merci bravo à vue
[Applaudissements]